for you what has been because I think
that the number one thing artists have
an issue with you mentioned it earlier
is somebody could get a tick tock moment
but it doesn't mean they have fans yeah
right you have done a good job of like
developing a fan base thank you what is
the hardest part about like connecting
with the people and making them give a
[__] about you
huh just it's gonna sound cliche but I
think it's just being yourself bro and
not just giving the [__] about like the
numbers you know what I'm saying like
even like with my last album I think
it's because I dropped at the top of the
year I did 24K first week everybody
reported at 20. I'm not going to Tweet
and be like no [__] I do 20 I did 24K
but whatever so I did 24K but I sold out
90 of a world tour and venues that's way
bigger than [__] that do triple
the numbers that I do right you get what
I'm saying so what's the point of doing
a 100K first week if you can't sell out
the novo you know what I'm saying or
certain venues that I'm doing me as a
with my little 24K and I'm doing triple
the venues and those people also aren't
turning down Million Dollar Deals nah
for sure on a 10 song conscious album by
the way you know what I'm saying so I
say this to say it's all about like what
connects you know just making music from
your heart that that relates to a
certain demographic or not even
demographic a certain Niche people who
or just whoever is for I'm I'm kind of
at the place right now I'm like yo bro I
just want to make music
it's trans with this new [__] I'm doing
bro I'm just more transparent than ever
ever
more vulnerable than ever more honest
than ever and whoever that connects to
is who's that was meant to connect to
and if it didn't connect to them I mean
and if that doesn't connect to whoever
then it's just not for you